a literary giant but Martin amos's
influence extended far wider than the
era defining novels he wrote the son of
Booker prize-winning novelist Kingsley
Amos he once described the Amos
franchise as something of a burden but
his talent for writing was evident early
on the process is
um
is saying the sentence
sub-vocalizing it in your head until
there's nothing wrong with it
he published
tizzy while he was working as a Toro
assistant times literary supplement
moving on to work for the new Statesman
whilst continuing his writing but it was
his 1984 novel money a Zeitgeist book
based on amos's own time as a
scriptwriter that brought him the global
recognition he deserved Martin he was I
think defined a generation a very
particular male voice of the 1980s and
90s he went on to publish a string of
notable works his contemporaries
including Salman Rusty Ian McEwen and
Julian Barnes but the author also became
known as an outspoken intellectual I in
common with many writers I think feel
that
feel that there is a
and this may be again just something
that every writer feels in every
generation but there's a great
convulsion of stupidity happening in the
world in a statement Penguin Books said
he leaves a towering Legacy and an
indelible mark on the British cultural
landscape and will be missed enormously
one of the most acclaimed modern
novelists Martin Amos and erudite and
fearless writer his the most distinctive
of voices Katie Spencer Sky News